you with me Tommy that is worse than I
remember
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones into the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we welcome back our dear friend
Tom Segura his latest special ball hog
is available on Netflix now and the man
is a podcast Factory your mom's house
two bears one cave and Tom Segura and
espanol wherever you get your podcast
this season were sprinkling in some of
our favorite past guests along with some
new faces and who better to welcome to
the table then my brother Gavin's
favorite all-time hot ones episode my
dear friend Tom Segura Tom welcome back
to hot ones it's good to be back Shawn
thank you for having me in this new
normal and that's good to be with you
are you in New York or your knees coasts
I'm in New York yes I can tell by the
NYPD that's the son of the police
[Music]
round two yeah let's do it let's hit it
[Music]
yeah that's nice
[Music]
so this pandemic strikes me as a unique
situation for comedians because on one
hand you have this universal singular
topic that everyone can relate to but on
the other hand it's this totally
miserable experience that everyone wants
to escape and there's been a lot of PR
fallout from celebrity sing-alongs two
famous people posting pictures by the
pool saying I'm bored why are moments
like these so difficult for celebrities
to navigate because we have like for
some reason believe that if you're
famous you are intelligent or
well-informed and know what to do and
then we go like you know hey this actor
really [ __ ] up this moment it's like
yeah well he's not a thinker he's a
[ __ ] actor we should stop being
surprised that actors or singers are
like not navigating the waters perfectly
because you know why would they why it's
our own expectations so we deserve to be
disappointed by it
I heard you put forth an interesting
theory on two bears one cave where you
suggested that despite being
larger-than-life Michael Jordan is a
much more relatable celebrity than say
John Travolta because of his line of
work when you're watching the interviews
the the specifically the interviews with
him and you're you're really thinking
about the fact that this guy is as
famous as anyone has probably ever been
on earth and you see what that does that
type of Fame what it does to let's say
entertainers artists right like singers
Madonna actors Travolta Garth Brooks
these people get like really famous and
they get kind of [ __ ] weird and my
theory is that it's all due to sports it
doesn't matter how you start in sports
it makes you kind of the same as the
next man so I think when you're around
those kinds of people it sort of brings
you down whereas if you're an actor
you're a singer you're around directors
PR people red carpets it's all about
being like you're amazing you're amazing
you're amazing and I think that does
something to their heads because those
three people as us it's beginning our
[ __ ] weird
[Music]
I overdosed but I'm doing it it's for
the people man dude see that's nice so
for the people was actually a rather
poetic segue into this next question
because you have maybe the most dialed
in fans have ever seen underneath this
video right now I'm sure the comments
are just filled with people telling us
to keep our genes high and tight and
begging Garth Brooks to give the family
closure as someone who understands the
art of humor what is the value of an
inside joke to you I don't know it's
like what's the value in a secret it's
almost like it's like when you tell a
secret to somebody you reveal something
and you guys have that bond and with
inside jokes it's like you're just
extending that bond it becomes like a
secret handshake or like a wink when we
did the drive-thru inside joke people
would record themselves doing it and get
elaborate and you know the drive-thru
person was like yeah what can I do for
you and it's like hey gene I was
wondering if you could put a hot bag of
poutine and Hitler would wondering if
you could give me some extra fries with
that and the first bill he had no
problem like they would never
acknowledge that someone is saying
insane [ __ ] to them and that that was
definitely one of my favorites
[Music]
how's this one still pretty light let's
see the big the big down there so when
our friend Bert Kreischer was on the
show last we drew back the curtain on
your guys legendary dance battle one
which Bert seems to freely admit that
you won but Bert did seem somewhat hurt
that post Malone didn't like his video
how big a deal was it from Missy Elliott
to actually reach out to you
come on dude that was unbelievable I
mean Missy Elliott it's it's it's hard
to describe you know what a genius this
woman is right like and she was a
pioneer in the style of song she was
making and of course those of us that
grew up with her know that she rewrote
the books on music videos like she has a
videos best video I mean to another
level and I think it bummed me out she
was like who do y'all think won
that was like her tweet when she
retweeted it I like the [ __ ] you talking
about clear is me and then also you
dressed up as Sensei Steven Seagal what
is that about Steven Seagal that makes
him such a prolific targeting comedy I
mean it's a number of things number one
he's the only person that in Mike's the
my limited experience in in Hollywood
that people are willing and freely to
talk immense [ __ ] about like people who
never gossip are like that guy's a piece
of garbage and like they'll tell you
stories to back it up incredible stories
I also enjoy that he is on this plan
right now to release like seven action
films a year
he's like 350 pounds he's fighting
people sitting down and the the premise
of the film's will be like we're in
Afghanistan you're like that's Milwaukee
I could see that's where the [ __ ]
Brewers play like they don't even try to
hide where they are all that combined
makes you go like man [ __ ] this guy
oh [ __ ] damn it
I've been dousing y'all of it dousing
that [ __ ] man still enjoyable we're
still in that spot still laughs weird
vibe so recently you made national
headlines for comments he made about
professional wrestling fans calling them
idiots and grouping them alongside flat
earthers and anti-vaxxers how did the
backlash this time around compared to
some of your past controversies I saw a
handful of active wrestlers like
threatened to beat your ass yeah yeah
yeah well we'd have to script it out but
yeah that would be fine
the funny thing about this was it was an
off-the-cuff just conversation on a
podcast but at the same time I also like
you know I don't care I think it's cute
that they play pretend I think it's
sweet that they have other friends that
dress up with them and you know I think
the fans that hey man you like what you
like you know some people like more
sophisticated things so people like
playing pretend I think is cute that
those people do and I support them no
comedian Matt McCarthy once compared
wrestling to stand up by saying that
essentially both are about a man alone
seeking justice presented in the most
amusing way possible yes and I do
respect the fact that look it is fun
like I've already told you I love bits
I love silliness inside jokes and I love
that they commit to these things and and
and that they're out for their you know
the it is that that form of
entertainment I do respect that they're
athletes so people were like all you're
trying to say these are not I think
they're definitely athletes they're not
fighters there's no such thing as a
champion that's my favorite thing about
wrestling they're like this guy's an
eight-time world champion like oh yeah
that's cute well is the Tooth Fairy
involved I don't know what like you're
not a champion if there's not a real
competition but that's never mind I'm
getting I'm getting sidetracked again
they're great
[Music]
all right Tom you're ready to move on to
five I almost accidentally grabbed ten
dogs out here when they don't set your
table for you all right how's this one
Oh brah that's a lot that's a big douse
that's a big time house all right all
right Tom as you know we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham where you do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context first things first
as a college football diehard do you
have a favorite memory from your day
doing long snaps at Memorial Stadium in
Lincoln Nebraska that was the best shout
out Jeremiah sir I mean I feel like that
was like that was a dream come true I
you know there's a couple of things
where you can't believe it's happening
to you that environment is what's so
great about college football like
specifically what they do at Nebraska it
was a thrill man the other one that by
the way that's been amazing is getting
to drive press cars so shout out to Matt
Phair the smoking tire that was like
yeah I'd love to be able to do it he was
like you can and then there was a
McLaren at my house the next day so I
love it while we're on the topic what's
your experience with tik-tok been like
so far well my experience with tick top
is that I'm married to a tick tock
addict but she has a whole theory on how
to experience tick tock the right way
she she says that tick tock wants to
want you to see like people scooping ice
cream and and playing on the sand but
there's a deeper darker lane of
tick-tocks that you have to find
Christina Pete hurt I'm tick tock she's
at the water champ but she finds these
like meth heads people committing crimes
older oversexed people and they're
really doing amazing work I I don't
deserve any of the credit she finds all
of it and shares it with me and it's it
really is remarkable tick tock is my
favorite social media platform
I just found out that my last post was
deleted because it violated Community
Guidelines well wait till you see what I
do next
whoa [ __ ]
god damn it I got that [ __ ] alright
[Music]
Oh smell young yeah mm-hmm getting real
over here yeah if it's real yeah so I
want to ask you about Dave Chappelle
8:46 set that dropped recently it's
interesting to me in many ways because
Entertainment has found itself really
flat-footed in these months of kovat and
social unrest music in particular seems
to have dropped the ball completely
hasn't captured anything in the
zeitgeist but if you look at what is
breaking through it seems to be the
voices of comedians does that surprise
you at all or in the comedy world are
people just sort of like yeah of course
it would be that way I don't think it's
surprising I mean there's really you
know there's amazing prolific thinkers
Chappelle was one of them he he did
something that is really [ __ ] hot man
Dave's whole thing has always been like
if you're not being funny be interesting
it's kind of a masterclass in that
forget about like the the climate and
this see how when he's not getting
laughs you're still so engaged that's
really one of the beautiful things about
it as as a piece of art you know he's
just that interesting yeah it's
interesting that you put it that way
because there is a lot of talk about
whether sets like Chappelle's or Hanna
Gatsby's specials are funny in the
traditional sense of a stand-up back do
you think that that's just like think
piece fodder or do you see something
broader shifting yeah I mean I don't
know if it's if we're gonna see a huge
shift in that is an interesting point
like you could you could see more and
more people do it but here's the thing
you better be [ __ ] good at it if
you're if you're like I'm not gonna joke
so much I'm just gonna you know share my
thoughts on something they better be
really interesting
the image yeah yeah it's on me all right
god damn it Tom I know your mouth is on
fire right now but we have a treat that
will hopefully bring you some comfort
we've reached out to two of your buddies
in the comedy world and ask them for
their burning questions for Tom Segura
so here they are and first up it is host
of tacos con todo a fellow comedian hey
Suz Trejo that has an important question
for you Tom Segura oh it's uh Pacers hey
Tom you're probably swing your ass off
right now I feel for you let me help you
out get your mind off of the pain you
must be having right now and I want to
ask you this what was your favorite
street joke from when you were a kid
thanks Brandon good luck
[Music]
all the good ones are pretty racist but
I think oh my god what was what was what
was Moby Dick's dad's name what was Moby
Dick's dad's name pop a boner all right
up next we have your buddy Bert
Kreischer with a very important question
Tom Segura comedian Bert Kreischer you
know who I am
if you can replace one actor as a
superhero in a superhero franchise what
superhero would you play what actor
would you replace and what would you
bring to the role that you feel that
that actor does not I didn't he had so
many questions within his question why
do you even allow them so would you be
why would you be who why would you think
what else feeling you who bring to the
party
what's your [ __ ] question man I feel
like I would be Batman which Batman
would I replace I mean Val Kilmer is
obviously and what would I break through
I mean much is just I'm more John blaze
than him man
bye tom careful around the eyes with the
napkin and that was that was pretty
[ __ ] dumb
you okay I have a lot of anxiety right
now my mouth hurts and I remember I told
your crew I remember how much this [ __ ]
is sucked
I remember the bomb was the one that
made me go [ __ ] my life yep you and me
both
[Music]
all right
[Music]
so like many I'm having a hard time with
basic manners and etiquette during the
pandemic so now it's one of comedies
most thoughtful Minds in front of me I
thought it'd be a great idea to get the
Tommy buns perspective on these new
everyday life challenges there are
reports that flushing the toilet
releases a plume of potentially kovat
infected particles up to three feet in
the air
are you flushing public toilets or is it
better to let sleeping blogs lie oh my
god oh my god fathom leave it buffets
are I PR too big to fail [ __ ] a buffet
who's going to buffet you go up the
feydau put those [ __ ] animals that
way they don't clean that [ __ ] and then
let me bounce a hypothetical off you you
see an older woman hobbling towards the
exit of a drugstore at the same time as
you [ __ ] hit her in the neck
what she's clearly over 70 and has
respiratory issues do you hold the door
open or do you let it slam shut for her
to fend for herself I mean I'm a
gentleman I'm gonna hold the door open
but I might tell her she should stay
home more often dude
that is worse than I remember
oh my god dude oh my god can we just
call it a wrap you can always call it a
wrap Tommy yeah we gotta go
oh my god
how's this one very hot quite hot Oh
[Music]
do you have a Mount Rushmore of comedy
specials for those of us who've already
seen every episode of 90 day fiancé
how [ __ ] good is that show it's the
best yeah
yeah you got to go delirious pick your
poison either bigger blacker or bring
the pain has to be on there oh my god
and then I feel like you gotta you have
to give one to Carlin you are all
diseased or jamming in New York it was
the greatest of what he did like the
style he did he's a great thinker too
like we were talking about like really
thoughtful he'd be fascinating to have
right now and the last one I probably go
with killed him softly Dave Chappelle
all right my man
[Music]
every time I do this I feel like it
really helps my sinuses
well there's one positive all right I'd
made a DAB all right me too
I put it on there cheers buddy
Cheers
[Music]
okay Tom here we are at the end of our
meal ten Blasi not chicken wings down
and only one stumbling block standing
between you and sauce Valhalla last time
you're on the show we left on a high
note and this time around we're hoping
to leave fans with the same warm and
fuzzy feeling
what's DJ dad mouths message of hope to
the mommies out there who eagerly await
the return of live stand-up yo 2025 it
sucks but it's building up it's building
up tension and pressure you know what
happens when pressure builds up shot
what happens something pops off then
something's going to explode we're gonna
be out there dancing groovin laughing
moving together again in huge venues
it'll be fun we'll be able to cough
again who spit in each other's faces
people will be having sex in front of
other people and it'll all be a fun
party it will be together fighting the
invisible virus
[Music]
I don't even know why I said I just hope
everybody gets their citizenship the
streets have spoken and look at you Tom
Segura back for another round of hot
ones and clearing the board for the
second time and now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you Tom Segura this camera or possibly a
camera B if you set one up let the
people know what you have going on in
your life oh my god well I am podcasting
a lot your mom's house podcast two bears
one cave Tom Segura in espanol we're
doing a lot of original content we're
putting it on all our YouTube channels
on Instagram I'll try to get back to
stand-up hopefully I'll be on stage soon
and on tour in a city near you
[Music]
you
you